chứ tập nhóm quái sế, ném bột và người đi đường.
Chết mạ sơ hội Facebook, sớt hiện có lýp dài khoảng 2 mây dây,
vì cảnh nhóm thánh kêu niên trải xe máy đua dân,
ném bột trên tướng thụ cu vực phường người thoá tình vĩnh lòng,
gây nguy hiểm trong người tham gia rau thông.
Quà sắc mình, phong kể xa rau thông công an tình vĩnh lòng,
đã mời làm việc nhóm thánh kêu niên nói trên.
Tại bùi làm việc, lực lượng kể xa rau thông đã,
giải thích, phân tức zong mất đổ nguy hiểm của hàng vi đua dân,
chạy xe hàng ngang khi tham gia rau thông.
Lòng gió các quy định của pháp lợt,
liên quan đến chặt tự ăn toàn rau thông đường bộ.
Tế nàynh chích xuất hiện ngàn thông tin phương tiện
để kiểm tra nếu kiện của người điều khiển phương tiện.
Sau khi cùng cố đây đủ tại liệu, chính cứ,
cơ quan chích năng, sẽ sự liên nghiêm cất trường hợp vi phạm
theo lúng quy định của pháp lợt.